hello guys hector mejia here back with
an update as you just read the caption
of this facebook live
firefighters put out a fire here at this
uh
lvmpd squad car
you can smell
and uh
you can see that it was charred you can
see
the inside of those stores that were
charred
right now you can hear the helicopters
above crowds are still here
here we have las vegas fire and rescue
and metro police
and it appears that a police squad car
was set on fire
uh it's already been out it's already
been put out by firefighters but this is
the scene unfolding here
now not too far from this location just
a couple of streets
nearby right at 7th and carson that's
where we saw
swat a whole group of swat
and uh what appeared to be tear gas
being launched at a crowd
one of the protesters was telling me
that he was struck by a rubber bullet
about half an hour ago
uh he shared video of those moments with
us we'll be posting that shortly let me
get out of the way
let me come back here
so yeah that was the squad car that
appeared that was uh set on fire
las vegas fire and rescue put it out uh
that's a scene there at ninth and carson
we're gonna roam around and bring you
these pictures here in the area